thanks
so i'm reporting this i do that for my
my students and some colleagues
that uh
i'd like to
see what's going on
um
this is part of a
larger project that i've been working on
for a while i'm writing a book on
aristotle and anger
that works across the corpus
and one of the the
the issues that comes up over and over
again in discussing
aristotelian
virtue ethics is this this problem like
what what is a pro-euresis actually
um like a lot of things in aristotle
the more that you dig into it and the
more you look at the commentators who
are digging into it the murkier it gets
um you'd expect that there'd always be
and everything would like fall into
place
that isn't the case for for this concept
at least
so i'm going to just read the paper
you've got handouts
sort of summarizing them
what exactly is the moral phenomenon
aristotle picks out in his works by pro
iracis interpreters of aristotle had in
several diverging directions for some
pro-races remains an unproblematic
concept whose entire nature and scope we
understand well enough from its nico
mccain ethics book 3.2 characterization
as deliberate choice
for others aristotle's conception of
prairie racist is not quite so simple
clear or straightforward
without simply rejecting the nico mccain
ethics 3.2 discussion such interpreters
sense that those passages cannot
comprise the entirety of the story some
suspect that a deep incoherence or
lacuna
underlies aristotle's numerous
discussions and uses of the term
others attempt to rework an aristotelian
notion of pro-racists into something
more amenable because more like to
conceptions germaine to later in moral
theories like the turn into the will
for example
others more optimistically attempt to
provide more or less integrated and
systematic interpretations ranging
across aristotle's corpus
the challenge for these the latter is to
rightly not the threads from aristotle's
writings together in ways that are
faithful to the texts and harmonious the
larger structure of aristotle's moral
theory and yet contribute some
additional understanding
my own interpretation
in my view solidly places me within this
last camp understandably some might
regard my advocacy of a more extensive
and robust conception of prior races
as exemplifying imaginative shoehorning
of aristotle's moral theories and the
confines of other later moral theories
it's going to look a lot like some
conceptions of the will
in this short paper i'll first briefly
present what i call a standard
interpretation of aristotelian prior
races centered on nickel mckinney nickel
mccain ethics 3.2
second i'll bring together some though
not all of the other passages from the
aristotelian corpus in which
proto-racist is discussed
third i'll suggest that implications of
these passages raise problems for the
standard interpretation
and i'll propose an alternate more
expansive interpretation of propriorasis
along the lines suggested by the
additional passages
for reasons of convenience and
consistency i'm going to render prior
racist heroes choice there's all sorts
of problems with how to translate it
exactly and there's also problems given
that different
translators have not been consistent
across the
english
renderings
due to limitations of length i don't
provide an account as full as that of
the longer study i'm presently working
on and i relegate portions of the
argument and discussion to footnotes
which is how i tend to get around the
reading time requirement
one would so this is the standard
interpretation one would understandably
expect aristotle's most definitive and
determinative treatment of prior races
to occur in nickel mccain ethics 3.2
particularly given the pains he takes
distinguishing it from other moral
phenomena and the fact that he finally
asks what is it and what sort of thing
is it his answer is that it's a subset
of the voluntary that is preceded by
deliberation since it does as he says
involve reason and thought
this aspect of involving reasoning and
deliberation is particularly important
explaining why according to aristotle
animals and children do not yet possess
it animals lack and children do not yet
possess it he also makes a broader
etymological point namely that the very
name signifies it involves choosing one
thing over another
or before another
or others so choice gets characterized
as intrinsically comprising deliberation
boulevardosis whose nature aristotle
examines in the following chapters
specifying its concern only with
determining means for ends
not in assessing comparing or ordering
ends themselves
other passages reinforce this connection
particularly
the characterization is as deliberate
deliberating desire or affectivity
depending on how you want to translate
arrexis about matters that are up to us
it is clarification that what is
deliberated about and what chosen are
the same except that what is chosen has
already been determined since the chosen
is selected as a result from the process
of deliberation
so the examples in these two chapters
seem to bear out choice's intrinsic
connection with the liberation for
example when he maintains it cannot be
rational desire
laces since we rationally desire ends
but choose only means for those ends it
thus seems reasonable to follow certain
translators and rendering pro-irasis as
delivered choice
what other key passages figure in this
standard interpretation
certainly aristotle's definitions of
virtue is such
in nick of mccain ethics 2 we learned
that virtuous action proceeds from
deliberate choice and that virtue is a
state expressive of such choice
in fact virtue and vice lie within our
power as states we develop through
actions and thus we are morally
responsible for them precisely because
it lies within our choice to engage in
actions characteristic and productive of
virtue or advice
again in nico mckay and ethics 6.2
choice gets brought in close parallel
with the liberation and gets called
deliberative desire and is framed both
as the determinative starting point the
arcing of actions and is informed in its
its turn by desire or affectivity and
reasoning towards some end passages in
the nicu mccain ethics the udamian
ethics and the diana consistently
construe lack of self-control across you
as failure to abide by one's deliberate
choice faced with desires demands and
self-control as sticking with one's
result
so what is pro-racist on this account
it's voluntary it's choice made between
alternatives it's informed by
deliberation selecting means to some and
desired is good it's closely connected
with those distinguishable from other
more important moral phenomena
and ambiguity has to be noted though
because prayer racist denotes not only
individual choices made on particular
occasions but also broader longer
lasting more characteristic patterns of
choice if this were not the case it
would make no sense to regard virtue and
vice as prohibited
one deliberates about and then chooses
what will move one towards one's
determinate end in specific situations
but one also deliberates on a higher
level of about what will move one
towards one overarching end happiness or
you have dymonia whatever shape one is
conceived
and so one may deliberate and then
choose on lower situational or on higher
global levels well or poorly rightly or
wrongly and be correspondingly praised
or criticized for it and for the actions
or emissions that follow from such
deliberate choices
this seems a highly intellectualist
account in which
one must deliberate that is explicitly
reason matters up through all
or at least much of the time in moral
matters
to possess a good pride racist it seems
that one must deliberate and choose
rightly both at the lower locally
particularized level and at a higher
more global level of one's life and
personality over time
likewise a bad pro-euresis whether it's
a single bad choice a particular vicious
disposition or as the structure of one's
entire personality would equally seem to
involve explicit deliberation
determining means to a given and
probably bad or misconceived end
so now the second section other relevant
passages
in aristotle's works people are morally
evaluated specifically on the basis of
choice
unsurprisingly the reasons aristotle
first seduces for thematically studying
prayersis in the discussion that we were
just looking at is that it is so
intimately connected with virtue and
permits as he says better judging of
people's characters than new actions
this makes sense given that virtue and
vice involve express and are
reciprocally produced by and productive
of pro-erasus
in the poetics it's consistently tied to
character actions and discourse the
latter of which reveal and embody
pro-erasius
it plays an important role in
aristotle's nico mccain ethics eight and
nine a treatment of friendship as well
where he says the return one should
render to one's friend is based on their
choice
for this in turn is determinative of the
friend and the virtue
rhetoric book one also mentions acting
in accordance with good choices
characteristic of a good person and i
actually put in a footnote one thing i
do want to bring up um it's funny
because in that one aristotle then goes
on to cynically provide advice about how
you might produce such an impression so
there's a certain vulnerability there
right
the association needn't necessarily be
with good character however aristotle
distinguishes between the sophist and
the dialectical philosopher precisely on
the basis of their pro-irasis in the
rhetoric
the choice and intention exhibited by
the use to which they turn argument
interestingly he says it's the sofas to
act in accordance with with choice
whereas the dialectician acts in
accordance with the discipline
of argumentation using it rightly
according to norms discernible within it
speaking in more general terms about
wrongdoing asl tells us that those who
choose do so because of vice or lack of
self-control
in distinguishing between degrees of
wrongdoing and responsibility whether a
person actually chooses to do wrong
plays an important role in aristotle's
views on how the act of the person ought
to be treated he says for wrongdoing and
vice reside in the choice
just as much as does genuine moral
goodness in fact the very names of some
classes denote their bad moral purpose
and their that's a translation of
proto-racist as well so clearly choice
is a nexus and target for moral
evaluation what makes it good or bad
in nico mccann ethics book six aristotle
tells us in order for the choice to be
good the rational faculty must be true
and the aff activity the arrexis must be
right and the aff activity must respond
accordingly to the things the rational
faculty shows us
this is precisely what truth in action
or practical truth concerned with
practical or productive activity
consists in
there's a reciprocity on the part of the
rational faculty
as well as well since the truth it
possesses must itself accord with
rightly structured affectivity
this juncture of practical intellect and
affectivity is essential to aristotle's
conception of promiracias which is in
fact where they meet and interfuse with
or interfere with each other he signals
this interconnection of intellect and
affectivity or reason and desire by
stating
choice is either effectively imbued
intellect
or intellectually oriented affectivity
which is how i translate this this
passage the words you know choice is
either erecting cos noose or orexis
following this up he emphasizes a near
identity between the human being and
their choice
in nick ethics book 612
aristotle tells us virtue rightly
directs us towards ends making the aim
and in fact the pro-racist right
practical wisdom or prudence by contrast
ensures that the right means the
underdetermined the relation between
these is in terms of means and ends
unless pro-racist and deliberation and
rational desire
is not so simple
or strictly dichotomous virtue in the
full sense cannot exist without prudence
he says not least because virtue is a
state in accordance with prudence that
is a state not only in accordance with
right reason but which is accompanied by
it
he says this is precisely why there
cannot be right prohibit racist without
prudence at least some degree of it or
without virtue since these enable to
rightly grasp and act in relation to
both means and ends
this formulation must not be interpreted
and applied in too strict to fashion
because the self-control and the
uncontrolled person do possess a prior
racist that is more or less right
that is along the lines of what virtue
and prudence would dictate or produce
though not caused by the presence of
virtue or prudence in the person
the self-controlled person remains
in it or follows it while the
uncontrolled person does not do this but
does still recognize it even regrets
abandoning it the vicious person by
contrast remains in and acts according
to choice
their choices are skewed because they
correspond with wrong starting points
for action that is ends
since vice corrupts those
in fact the mistaken moral choice of a
vicious person partly consists in making
the wrong things into ends for instance
in the case of the self-indulgent person
who pursues excesses of pleasures or
pleasures excessively through their own
choice aristotle says for the sake of
those very pleasures not for the sake of
anything else
so this brings us to a last important
point in evaluating priorities it's
always determinatively oriented by some
ends
in the process grasping
realizing even ordering matters is good
and bad understanding them under aspects
of what we can call broadly moral values
here i'll confine myself to noting three
dimensions of this
first aristotle explicitly notes
distinct but intersecting moral values
as matters of pro-racist for example in
nickel mccain ethics book two chapter
three where there are he says three sets
of values of concern for moral choices
and avoidances the positive ranges are
the noble the colon the useful or
profitable the pharaoh and the pleasant
the hatem the negative are the base the
harmful and the painful
clearly to these we have to add the the
just and the unjust the decay and
modical
second is that passage continues the
good person is likely to get these
values right and the bad person is
likely to make mistakes so in nick
mccain ethics 3.4 the good person
embodies a correct standard and judges
accordingly when it comes to such
matters in particular
about what is genuinely noble and
pleasant aristotle focuses on hexis that
is their moral state and
laosis their rational desire for ends
perceived as goods in that passage which
is literally sandwiched between two
connected discussions thematizing choice
the second of which argues that virtue
and vice are voluntary because they
express pro-eurosis
not because they express priorities but
because they are cumulatively produced
by prior racists
third if we go back to pro-iraqis
etymology which involves the sense of
taking or choosing
and the sense of comparing and setting
things over each other the pearl in it
we must now recognize that pro-racist is
not just selection among possible means
to previously given or rationally
determined as it extends to ordering
goods and values in relation to each
other in ongoing practical life a
determinant relation of the person and
their choices
moral habits actions even emotional
responses
and relationships to what we can
recognize as a hierarchy values
so now the third section expanding the
standard interpretation i don't want to
say we get rid of it entirely i just
want to say we have to make room for
further dimensions
so these brief
peregrinations through aristotle's text
suggest an understanding of prohibi
racist incorporating but going beyond
this standard interpretation in this
last section i'd like to offer some
outlines of what an expanded model would
look like
my view as an interpreter of aristotle
is that his discussions of and
references to prior races are
understandably confusing because he
didn't adequately distinguish different
though connected senses of the term
corresponding to different analogically
related sides of the phenomena
so i intend this this last section to do
two interrelated things one is to try to
disentangle these these senses from each
other
the other is to suggest why the the
standard interpretation has to be
challenged and expanded so let's start
with the latter
we've seen that proirasis is a source
for intentional human action and that it
provides a locus for the moral
evaluation of a person as well as their
actions moral habits or states and
structures of motivation and valuing it
provides a window into a person's
character precisely because it is woven
into it at so many points
inextricably connected with virtue
advice desires and practical reasoning
ends and means development or
degeneration even self-control or its
lack
one of the key questions we have to ask
is this
does prayer racists always at every
point explicitly involve deliberation
about means to give and ends
granted in many cases even many
paradigmatic cases it does
but is moral choice what makes a person
a good or bad person always a matter of
practical reasoning setting before
oneself some good understood as an end
examining the possible means assessing
and comparing them in terms of their own
various goodness or badnesses selecting
one of them perhaps even reasoning
further about what means would best lead
to that particular means
is it only on such an intellectual basis
that people do choose and act establish
or express their characters
when we say that a person is good or bad
that this goodness or badness is
embodied in their choices their
motivations their priorities what they
apparently desire and value
or is the effective habitual and
relational basis of moral life just as
important equally determinative in a
person's choices the choices that make
him or her the kind of person he or she
is we might try to say that moral choice
is always a matter of previously worked
out deliberation but we know this isn't
the case
alternately we might construe it as
involving deliberation in a more shadowy
manner perhaps perhaps hypothetically or
counterfactually or perhaps understood
as a more implicit process the good
person can not only can not only reason
rightly about means and ends but also is
rightly oriented effectively in those
manners and matters
so when it comes to moral preference
in the sense of you know where it's
cognate to proliferation the pre is as
opposed to the probe the ferrets
the hierarchies
while the good person acts and chooses
rationally with right affectivity
consonant to true reason they often do
so without any explicit process of
practical reasoning
so there's good reason to decouple
proirasis from necessary connection with
deliberation in a strict sense
what about means and ends is it true we
deliberate solely about means inquiring
into acquiring determining reevaluating
ends only by other means
is it true that our moral choice
concerns only means or do we ever call
our ends into question
realize that we've been pursuing the
wrong ends guiding ourselves by them in
reason habit feeling and action do we
ever decide upon the need for moral
reformation to write our already wrongly
established course
is this experience available to a strict
aristotelian
certainly in a trivial sense it is
because we can always displace the end
and its considerations to
reconceptualize eudaimonia we can only
say well you just didn't know what
eudaimonia really was
but in a more robust sense again we
ought to ask what are people morally
praised and blamed for
is it not at least in part for their
very choice
their commitment to and conscious
endorsement of ends their orderings and
prioritization prioritizations of goods
their hierarchies of value
the question remaining open is whether
aristotelian pro-irasis can be extended
to such extent to bearing upon at least
some ends
the standard interpretation i think is
to take leibniz's famous phrase over
true in its affirmation but false in
denial and restrictiveness i propose
that we view pro-racist as a complex and
multi-layered phenomenon corresponding
to an analogical term who senses
aristotle does not rigorously
distinguish
but he could
go to aristotelian grounds at present i
would distinguish at least three
different senses and levels of pride
races the first sentence denotes
particular morally significant choices
made by a person in specific
circumstances voluntary most likely
involving deliberation exclusively about
means to some extent
we ought to distinguish a second wider
sense transcending but integrating
individual choices so as to form an
identifiable and specific pattern this
is where we have virtues and vices
also self-control in its lack at a level
where deliberation will often but not
always be involved i would like to
suggest that we also understand
aristotelian prohibitions at a third
more substantive level the nexus of the
moral person a manifold of fundamental
and either integrated or discordant
attitudes beliefs choices actions and
affectivity i would further suggest that
at this third global level of pro-races
the person would be involved in and
responsible for
choice of their ends as well as means
thank you
yeah i'm just a very quick uh
clarification question and this is going
to reveal how unfamiliar i am with
aristotle's ethics but um
is is prominent racist something that we
cultivate
because you mentioned that animals and
children don't possess it an animal
could not cultivate it but children will
children eventually acquired aristotle
is very unclear about how precisely this
happens
we know that but adults happen and uh
and it can be good or bad in them um and
children don't have it and he never
really talks about the okay so if it's
the case that the good person is likely
to get moral questions right and a bad
person conversely is likely to get them
wrong
i i i was just wondering if aristotle
ever says or we can change our pro
choices
can we get worse
that's why it's so tempting to try to
assimilate
pro-racists in aristotle's sense
to something like the will that you see
in in cicero or augustine or or later
authors where there's a reflexivity to
it
our pro-races
bear upon our pro-iracists once we
become conscious of that now epictetus
writing you know
um several hundred years after aristotle
explicitly does that with the term
pro-erasus
and and there's good reason to
make a case for translating pro-racism
epithelius as well okay
for aristotle it's it's not quite at
that level yet but it is we're yeah it's
where we make our choices and i think we
have to have a multi-layered account or
else we can't
what he's saying can't really add up now
aristotle unfortunately um
didn't
do that but but i think he could you
could do that in good versatility in
grounds
in a way it's fortunate because then we
get to do it yeah
we have something to talk about and
actually just building on that because
as you were when i had read your paper a
couple of times uh and your question
prompted me to go right to a particular
passage i think would help your
interpretation
and um
where he's discussion discussing when
people
get double penalties for being drunk
doing bad things while they're drunk uh
this is uh you may or may not have
terence berman's translations i'm just
going to work with kids and irwin is one
of those guys who wants to push
aristotle towards you know it's the will
it's true so i didn't bring my oct sorry
for us to look at it but uh the way in
which the discussion goes and i don't i
think that the translation here is
pretty um is pretty sound actually
they impose the uh the penalty in other
light cases for any other ignorance that
seems to be caused by the agent's
inattention they assume it is up to him
not to be ignorant since he controls
whether he pays attention yeah and still
he uh and they say well he's presumably
the sort of person who is an attentive
so he already has a disposition or
character outside of control but
aristotle says still
he is himself responsible for becoming
this sort of person because he has lived
carelessly so he's made prior choices
and so you can control what you intend
to or not whether you want to be sloppy
or not and and you could and in other
passages talks about changing that yeah
and rehabituating or getting friends to
a tendency sometimes to see that passage
as
similar to incontinence or crossing or
lack of self-control
and it's interesting because there's
there's a um
and the problem within you know lacrosse
is well the person has priorities they
just don't follow it so are they
responsible for their they're not
following it on the account that i'm
giving i would say yes that's yet
another type of priorities and the
person who like is you know careless in
the way in which they take care of their
character and winds up being
sloppy and inattentive they're they're
responsible for that
even though in a certain sense they
didn't you know strictly deliberate and
say i want to be the kind of person who
does this
um in the poetics aristotle actually
talks about the need if you're going to
make somebody inconstant you need to
make them reliably and
which implies that even in in constancy
there is a kind of
determinative character that we can
point to
and that would be a matter of progresses
so
yeah forgive me for the uh
ill-forming of this question it's been a
while since i've dived into uh the hours
just detailing stuff but um i remember
when i was reading the nike mccain
ethics uh when he's talking about you
know
voluntary he says you know it's not
you can't be a state of ignorance for
something to be voluntary rather if
you're ordering something at a
restaurant i i say something in a
language you don't understand you say
yeah i have that i don't really
voluntarily you know it could be a
council
right
and um you can't be coercive if somebody
turning gun to your head is not
voluntary right yeah so when talking
about this promoresis um
you say it's a species of the voluntary
right that's that's the standard
interpretation oh okay standard rotation
um
but i'm curious um this is now
anachronistic but you know we have
modern modern debates about
compatibilism and liverpool and all that
you know just because you're not in the
state of ignorance or not course doesn't
mean you're free though right in a
libertarian sense so
this pro a racist
as an original scholar do you think
based on your reading of him that he
might have been in his own incoherent
fuzzy way leaning a little more towards
libertarianism with this stuff or more
towards a compatibilism kind of thing
what do you think of that
i think that well if i have to take a
sort of definitive stand and place it
within that framework i would say that
aristotle is
you're you're going to
have him be a
libertarian
okay to some degree because we are um
self movers
uh to to some degree in that we choose
our reactions uh now you know in a lot
of areas i think you know especially
when you look at the connection between
mind and body
um which is stuff more in the dianoma
and
the physical texts
he he tends to analyze phenomena
particularly phenomena that are
important to moral life
in terms of like well there's this
physical level and then there's this
psychological level and then a moral
level yet and he doesn't i mean he's not
like actually coming out and saying here
we shall distinguish the three levels or
anything like that but you can see this
in his text
and he recognizes there's some
interaction
um you know for example he says once you
get angry his view of anger physically
is it's one stirring around the heart
boiling and all that once you actually
do get angry it's hard to like stop
yourself not only because we have
natural tendencies to be jerks and like
you know think that we have right
we're right we're being angry and by god
i'm going to show that guy but also
because the blood's still boiling and
moving around
so there is some element of
compatibilism in his account
but
i think that ultimately
and probably you know get in trouble
with other restaurants
he's got to be a libertarian
on some some level um as far as like the
ignorance and the the compulsion goes
there's there's
there's more voluntary stuff to that
because you're you get off the hook if
you're ignorant and you're ignorant of
particulars if you're ignorant because
you're the kind of person who like put
yourself in like let's say you go to
restaurants all the time and you order
off the menus and you got no idea what
what it is and that's your thing no
you're responsible right
or the waiter comes that's the habitual
side yeah yeah yeah or you know or i
mean it could also be because you get a
charge out of it so it has to do with
you know f activity or something like
that
or you want to you know you want to
you're at a french restaurant you don't
know any friends you want to impress
your date and uh like try to order
something and you're like yeah i'll take
that and it comes in
something terrible that you don't eat
as far as the compulsion goes
um
aristotle says that most of the cases
that we think of compulsion are actually
voluntary and involuntary they're what
he calls mixed actions
because you don't choose to be placed in
the situation where somebody holds a gun
to your head or his example is
threatening your your your your parents
and children to get you to do some some
dishonorable deed
um
you know there's always these forced
choices you do still choose he says you
do still select
an option into that in that respect it's
voluntary but you didn't choose to have
somebody come along and say if you don't
do this i'm going to bring this terrible
thing to you so it is to some degree
involuntary but it's it's mixed and he
never really
never really takes that back up
uh so apparently he doesn't consider it
a
big problem it is a big problem for us
so much he could do it his time he wrote
a lot but thanks i appreciate it sure
yeah
i get in light of uh our keynote uh talk
today
good morning if you saw any any room for
an issue like intuition when you're
talking about
uh we do make relevant moral choices
displaying character on basis of habit
affectivity without exclusive process of
practical reasoning is this aristotle
opening up a possibility that that at
times we
we just have an intuitional
uh awareness of of right and wrong and
great
yeah it's not it's not like we have a
faculty in the way that some
intuitionists historically have made it
out you know
and it's not like the reason i distrust
the talk about intuitions is it's very
leveling yeah you know and it tends to
face um
are asking questions about where exactly
did you get these ideas are right and
wrong that you're going with as gut
instincts you know are either the
product of choosing the wrong thing or
you know um
you know
incorrectly ordering your desires and
values in relation to each other and
then now you're sort of going on on that
basis
or is it you know conversely is it a
problem because of your self-discipline
that you've been engaged in
and there is also this this
dimension of for aristotle um
you know
locker fortune plays a role in it if you
know you wound up in the wrong culture
you're probably going to be
morally incapacitated you're going to
have the wrong what we call intuitions
particularly if you're one of those
barbarians by the black sea you know
you're worse than a persian then
you know
he's got you know he's got that whole
anthropology which which is kind of
clean now
um
but yeah
i don't like to use the word intuition
because then once you do i like open up
the door to anything becomes an
intuition all right
did you have a question
that kind of piggybacks on like dawn
grace because uh
on your page about nine out of ten it's
a discussion about um
does it really have to be this
intellectualist or community
do people really do this you know this
explosive process of practical reasoning
and i think there may be two at least
two things that could be said in
response
one of them
has to do with um
the fact that
aristotle says you do i you know ideally
the best person is going to be very
deliberate and such uh and
yeah um
but that will come in really handy when
you're in emergency situation so you
have to to choose out of what he calls
second nature yeah and so it looks like
it's not been deliberated about but
you're relying on your own good
cultivation and so it looks like one of
those uh you're doing the right thing
without thinking about it when actually
you thought about it and you got
yourself into the good habit that could
be one
one one way he would respond to your
suggestion here the other one is that
being this mudaya so the you know the uh
the franny moss
is is really hard and very rare and
that's uh that this section it depends
on the board yeah they're they're all
over there
it's relatively rare yeah and the second
best is to be
have your wits enough about you to know
to imitate the right person and so you
may not be
you have may have somewhat incoherent
wow that person's
really admirable or life's going really
well and i'd like to emulate them
because i don't
have the time or whatever to think
through but there's some kind of and and
maybe that's where the the wiggle room
for what you're suggesting for aristotle
is when you say that
do we have to have this explosive
process of practical reasoning
to enough of an extent on his account
you would have to but if you're
imitating a morally virtuous person yeah
and you're counting on you have to have
good enough judgment to know to follow
the right person and to reassess when
you need to yeah exactly that wow you
know maybe i've been you know going to
go off the cliff with the wrong wording
or yeah so you have to
then
have enough it's about you to switch
over so at some point on his view it
seems you have to have
at least some nautica with the
intellectuals account yeah for in order
to
to to have the judgment to do it so even
if not the full blown so your question
is a good one i'm just wondering where
you would stop
and the ground number two would stop and
say well no it has to be explicit it's
at some point at some
juncture for some length of time
i don't think there's a hard and fast
rule for that and it will probably
depend on the sort of moral quandaries
and how difficult
the situation of development is for the
person
looking at this really sort of big
picture you know broad broad project
kind of stuff what attracts me to virtue
ethics is exactly the sort of thing that
you're talking about we're not virtuous
most of us if we are it's usually in
respect of you know a few of the virtues
and not all of them we're always sort of
like picking up the pieces of lives that
we've managed to screw up so far
and want to unscrew you know to some
degree
and i think that that's something that
gets left out of virtue ethics but that
virtue ethics gives us lots of powerful
tools for her conceptualizing i see that
more in you know in christian virtue
ethicists particularly the monastic ones
because that was you know where their
focus was john cassian or anselm or you
know augustine to a certain extent um
aristotle wasn't concerned with all
those sort of problems but you know he
was
concerned with this and i tend to look
at
virtue itself as something that's on
gradient it often gets presented like an
on off switch where look you're either
just or you're not
and now you've got this somehow
somewhere along the line this this thing
got established in you this hexis and
now you're you're a-okay all the time
i don't think that's that's what he's
putting forth um certainly when you
start looking at like you know where
he's actually talking about real people
like athenian constitution or the
politics or or the rhetoric and he's
bringing up actual people he doesn't
think that most of them
are uh that they possess all the virtues
even if they have some of them some
other virtues
um
any other uh questions yeah i was just
gonna say that i think he did a really
good job of showing how the standard
interpretations is really limiting
because i was i was just thinking that
it looks to me as though the standard
interpretation of pro horizon is
subject to the same kind of critique
against utilitarianism of the
psychological demandingness of
individual choices and the one fought
too many kind of
you know sort of intellectual acrobatics
that you'd have to go through to to make
the right utilitarian choice nobody ever
really applies to the philippine
calculus yeah exactly and since it's
focused on choice
and it's like instances of choice
instead of really patterns of choices it
seems really just sort of
yeah you know aristotle in politics i
think it's in book seven okay he says
three things make us good logos reason
or speech you know however you want to
translate that
um
nature phusis
and then
ethos
habit character that's this whole
dimension where we have to work on
ourselves
and yeah you're right you know we
couldn't possibly
deliberate all all the time we go nuts
you know
i don't you know i i see that criticism
get raised against utilitarianism i'm
not utilitarian myself but but
i never liked that criticism because i
don't think that bentham or mill or
situated people like that are actually
saying we should do that every single
time bill explicitly takes on that
challenge it's like the ninth counter
example he takes on
utilitarianism yeah because yeah that's
a that's a strong man life yeah but i
think some act utilitarians
interpret it differently you know he
explicitly says that's not what we can
right so mill handles it
and he tries to suck in virtue ethics
he also said jesus was utilitarian wow
yeah it's nice you can get jesus on your
side and then you want to get jesus on
your side and somehow have hitler in
your opponent's camp and then your
rhetorical path is completely
thanks